il s'apprête à revivre l'aventuré la
plus folle des années 20 celle d'une
poignée d'hommes qui avaient juré coûte
que coûte de faire passer le courrier de
toulouse à dakar en quelques jours grâce
à une invention révolutionnaire l'avion
pour réaliser ce tour de force
121 hommes perdront la vie presque un
mort tous les 100 kilomètres sur la
ligne qui reliera bientôt toulouse à
santiago du chili
car pierre latécoère a confié cette
entreprise à un homme à la poigne de fer
didier daurat qui ne tolérait de ses
pilotes aucune faiblesse
comme s'en souviennent les rares
survivants mais jamais car si didier de
rein et est tyrannique avec ses pilotes
c'est aussi lui qui a forgé les mermoz
saint-exupéry et autres guillaume et
c'est sur leurs traces que les 14
équipages de ce rallye aérien toulouse
saint louis du sénégal espère passer
pour faire un peu partie de la légende
bien sûr ça évoque là tous les pionniers
de l'aviation mermoz saint-exupéry le
trajet d'un projet fabuleux je pense que
tous les pilotes privés rêvent un jour
ou l'autre de faire ce trajet jusqu'à
saint louis du sénégal
on va voir des choses que saint-exupéry
mermoz ont vu il ya 70 ans qui sont
pratiquement inchangé à part les
villages où on va se poser et qui
accueille la démographie assez galopante
et maintenant mais à l'époque
le dessert était à peu près le même et
dont on va revoir ces mêmes paysages
sont 110 après ces images d'immensité
les pilotes ont pu les revoir en
longeant la côte du roussillon et même
en atterrissant ce soir alicante
certains avaient l'impression d'avoir
déjà un pied dans le désert